qu'est ce que je vais faire de ma vie je
suis si pâle jeu devrait sortir plus
souvent manger mieux
je me tiens super mal je devrais me
tenir plus droit les jambes respecterait
plus si je me connais mieux qu'est ce
qui ne va pas chez moi ce que je veux
c'est communiqué pourquoi je n'arrive
pas à oui c'est vrai c'est parce que je
suis mort je devrais pas être aussi dur
avec moi même on est tous morts cette
fille est morte ce mec-là aussi celui
qui est dans le camp il est
définitivement mort en mon dieu ils sont
tous offrent eux
je voudrais bien me présenter mais je ne
me souviens plus de mon nom enfin je
crois que ça a commencé par un air mais
après je sais plus je me souviens ni mon
nom ni de mes parents ni de ce que je
faisais mais mon allure laisse supposer
que j'étais chômeur
parfois je regarde les autres et je me
demande ce qu'il faisait
toi tu étais concierge
c'est le bon
toi tu es un fils à papa blindés
doite été coach sportif
maintenant tu es morte j'ai eu du mal à
comprendre comment cette apocalypse
était arrivé il aurait pu venir d'une
guerre chimique ou d'un virus aéroportée
et d'un singe devenu radioactifs mais ça
n'a plus vraiment d'importance
voilà où on en est
c'est une journée habituelle pour moi je
traîne par ci par là je bouscule des
gens sans être capable de m'excuser ou
de dire quoi que ce soit
ça devait tellement mieux avant quand
les gens ressentais des trucs qu'ils
pouvaient les exprimer ou juste qu'on
profitait les uns des autres
beaucoup d'entre nous ont élu résidence
dans cet aéroport je sais pas pourquoi
dans les aéroports c'est vrai on attend
mais nous je sais pas trop ce qu'on
attend
ah oui on les appelle les eaux se il
nous dérange pas beaucoup mais il mange
tout ce qui est un coeur qui bat enfin
moi aussi mais moi au moins je
culpabilise on va tous finir comme un
jour arrive où tu perd tout espoir
tu abandonnes et c'est le point de non
retour oh non stop et arrête tu ne fait
qu'empirer les choses
et voilà ce qui m'attend c'est pas cool
je veux pas être comme ça je suis seul
le super du en fait là je suis
réellement perdu je suis jamais venu
dans cette partie de l'aéroport
lui c'est mon meilleur ami
par meilleur ami j'entends qu'on se
regarde en grognant bizarrement fixement
parfois on a presque réussi à avoir des
conversations
oh
les jours passent ainsi
mais quelquefois on arrive à trouver des
mots du genre et
donc là